all right it's been four months since we
heard from him
let's go first to Jimmy from Philly to
see what's on his mind Jimmy it's been
so long what's going on Danny but it's
been long because you're not advertising
your your your call and shows on YouTube
no that's not true every time we go live
there is a notification that goes out if
you are signed up to the notifications
David yeah I used to get the
notifications now I'm not getting them
that's your problem so here look I'm
holding up there it is David Pakman show
is live now so I'm holding up for the
audio no I got this one obviously that's
why I'm here but I don't get any other
callings is there any weather Rawlins
not live show this is very meta so if we
can talk about the live call shows or
you can maybe ask a question or make a
comment to I can ask a question you're
actually going to answer and not guess
likely what do you think about that
this whole impeachment thing is don't
you think that I mean common sense says
it's gonna hurt the deaths they got
nothing to impeach them for well I don't
agree with that but we're I do maybe CIA
I with you Jimmy is that there is a risk
here that it backfires on Democrats and
I want to be really clear you're saying
it's gonna backfire on Democrats I think
because you're saying there's nothing
impeach a bull is that correct correct
yeah I think it could backfire on
Democrats because Donald Trump is very
good at self victimizing and downplaying
what is in the news as evidence then he
should be impeached right well that's
why we're having a damn play and all
that ain't gonna matter well we will see
how the inquiry goes then I mean that
that's my field honest there's real
evidence to impeach him yeah and impeach
of course he'll be acquitted in the
Senate everyone knows that I agree with
you a Republican Senate is not going to
convict him there's no question right
just like they didn't conviction and
claim was guilty as hell Clinton why
didn't hear any obstructed justice he
tried to get that girl to testify a
certain way Jimmy oh yeah
in Arkansas you sound lucid this evening
are you drinking no not at all I don't
drink as much David because I do LSD
every weekend and it helps me you know I
can notice you you are noticeably more
lucid than when you've called in drunk
so I appreciate that Jimmy
well even they're not psychedelics help
you yeah they're not what do they help
you do I don't know I just did you know
whereas before I would go and impulse go
buy some beers now I think about it and
say yeah I'm really need that you know
my name's in effect can kind of control
B before ya know I don't know all right
very good Jimmy and his landscaping
slowing down now that we're getting into
the colder season slightly will be
doubly - good very good and any advice
the other day do you advise me let me
get some advice from you Jimmy do you
advise me to rake my leaves in batches
as they come down to avoid having to do
it all at once or do you recommend
letting them all fall and then doing it
in one shot well firstly David I doubt
that you're gonna rake you're gonna hire
somebody but no I rake my only one i
rake my only thing I do well depending
or like like if we have a house with 50
trees yes we'll do it three or four
times but evenly spaced like every two
weeks genius but if it's a house with
not much we might wait to the end of the
year but generally you should rake them
up because certain leaves are acidic and
can mess up your lawn so you know I mean
once you get a covering there every ten
days or so you can do it but if I could
back back flower David makes it easy oh
yeah I don't know I mean are those gas
powered I don't want any gas power tools
yeah I only do elect I don't want to
keep gas around the house yeah well you
could you you could probably buy a
decent electric backpack I don't know
but that tax the way to go I mean you
don't even have to rake David you know
even though the rake you just blow it
very good all right hey Jimmy thank you
so much appreciate the phone call thank
you have a good one very good
all right Jimmy see I can have
reasonable conversations with whoever
that is that is proof of it for sure